[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
my father is from um my father was a
street guy
my father during the korean war used to
hustle he never went to school he was in
gangs and stuff and then he joined the
korean military but my dad was a hoodlum
so i'm from
you know i mean korean trash almost you
know i mean
like you know so it's like and then we
my dad works hard and we live in the
suburbs but i'm around all these you
know white girls and stuff they don't
want nothing to do with me so it's like
you know you get drunk you're 15 16
and your friend pulls out his penis you
know i didn't
i made a mistake no you're very sexual
you were highly sexual
and i used to go to those like f street
in san diego we had those f street
bookstores and they used to have those
um masturbation booths
you remember those you sneak in you go
in the back and the floor is sticky it
makes a sound
are they people having live sex or no
you would close the door
you close the door and then you put you
know i mean dollar bills or quarters in
right or
f street had these tokens you had to go
to the front right you know give them 40
bucks and then they give you tokens and
you put the tokens and then there's a
button there's two buttons like you know
i mean changing channels and they were
always like a puddle of comma you know
do you have to stick your fingers in put
a little clump was this before the
internet or why would you go there yeah
this is a night late 80s
right
jesus so people was that no but they had
vcrs by then right yeah but i went to
them yeah i was a kid he was a kid i was
19. i'm not gonna go home to my parents
house yeah what i had when i was a kid
was you go in and there was a bed in the
middle
where
that was his number yeah
uh there was a bed in the middle and
there was a guy [ __ ] like this fat
chick
and then live live then there'd be
windows all around on 42nd street same
thing you walked in you locked the door
you put talking the window would slide
up yeah and then there was the ones that
had the plexiglass that you just watched
and people would [ __ ] you could look
around and see the guys jerking off like
bad's banging it's [ __ ] creepy man
what did you ever jerk off in those oh
[ __ ] yeah when i was 15 yeah yeah you
have to you don't know you don't know
that's the first time you see like
somebody actually [ __ ] in the front and
you could smell a [ __ ]
yeah you could say let you in at 15.
they didn't give a [ __ ] they weren't
proof that's probably in the 70s right
that's the 70s man they didn't proof yet
jesus christ and you'd walk in and
there'd be a great uh there'd be a
[ __ ] janitor and he'd go into every
room where the door would open and
somebody would walk out before he'd go
in there he'd go in and drop them up and
[ __ ] mop and put it back in with all
sperm and [ __ ] and then you go in there
put and you had to be careful what you
touched
and they'd have sex in front i think i
did it twice guys you know just being
young and stupid but then there was
times i was in the city i just go in
there just to see what was going on
you got a girl or what uh no i'm i'm
single now what happened uh we were
together for four and a half years and
i'm not ready to get married oh okay
we're still close we're still friends
but he's been going on new days lately
yeah we've recently been dating it's
been interesting no boundaries are you
high right now a little bit yeah yeah
you seem very high right now wait until
later with you
are you getting more high now because
you seem a little high right now no no
he doesn't want to stop
like he like whether you're a wreck
you keep asking me you constantly ask me
do you want me another hand sure i gotta
ask you because you look a little
uncomfortable did you eat one of these
gummies yet or what yeah yeah that and
uh something else what do you mean we
have a little mushroom you did sure
what's a mushroom cap just a little
mushroom and what does that do it makes
you see things
but why do you do that now because on a
monday because that's the reason why
everybody wants to do [ __ ] on friday
professionals do [ __ ] on monday night
stuff on friday too huh you do stuff on
fire
in those days she used to linger on
mondays too bobby lee
and she throw a tail on and [ __ ] like
that and pablo francisco and danger
and put me behind one of those savages
or something and then i go in between
dane cook
and eddie griffin would show up and do
six hours
but you know she was lingering on monday
so that confidence
and then one day i got a call at my
house hey man
they're looking for your mad tv
what are you talking about matt tv i'm
not a grounding
i'm not a [ __ ] rounding my tv is not
going to save me
are you [ __ ] crazy
boom i went in read for the check he
said sit here run for some other check
can you shoot tomorrow yeah no can you
rehearse tomorrow went in there
we didn't shoot in front of the live
audience that's what you say pretend if
i were to shout in front of a live
audience for mad tv i would have got
fired
why do you say that because i know i
could i would have fell apart
oh bobby lee are you [ __ ] not that
early bobby
not that early that's being thrown to
the wolves that's 18 type [ __ ] going out
there and hitting it in front of a live
audience but then you would have seen me
do it and you'll be like oh i can do
that because i was a [ __ ] up
i wouldn't never i go line and they go
it's yes
yes
i would have failed at the scene that
mad tv would have been in front of a
live audience when they told me it was
tape
like i i got i went home and didn't do
blow
like i knew there was a guy was that in
the scene
what with you
no this was
four years before you this is oh
oh
this was 2 000. will sasso was in it
and the chick who i always see she's
always in studio city there nicole
garcia and nicole sullivan
nicole garcia's who cast me yeah
nicole's the past the best she's the
best and there was just uh lee when i
walked off the mad tv set
that's the first time i really told [ __ ]
as a comedian
because to me i knew i wasn't gonna be
on saturday live but
i got mad tv okay what'd you get yeah
yeah yeah let me bump somebody tonight
missy shirt
why are you bumping because i did mad tv
mitchie sure let me get up there and
[ __ ]
and then you get bumped by james stevens
iii playing the [ __ ] piano and [ __ ]
oh my god lee are you okay yeah he's
fine yeah but you just seem like you're
drifting in and out of that that's what
he does every day i know but you you you
looked over there and then you started
thinking about something and there's my
little retirement yeah are you [ __ ]
no no he's he's just not i've been i
haven't been tested yet but i think i'm
okay yeah some tranquilizers yeah
yeah he's a good man that friday i mean
i had people in miami and i bought blow
in miami that friday and then that
thursday i got high but that saturday i
was talking to the waitress
and the waitress comes over to me and
they go hey man can you get some blonde
she goes yeah so i go how much 90
whatever i give her the money
20 minutes later the club manager comes
in he goes hey man
don't ever ask my waitress for blow
again i mean she ain't giving it to me
already yeah he goes next time come to
me
that's not where i thought you were
going with it yeah
i go i didn't know nobody [ __ ] sent
me the memo you know next time i'll go
to you yeah okay
that sunday night where the club owner
was i don't need to mention his name
i do the early show at seven [ __ ]
show finishes at 8 30. do you know what
11 o'clock i still wasn't paid
because he was doing blow in the green
room with whoever the [ __ ] some other
one of the other headliners and i could
even smell the free basin
okay
i bought the grandma coke
i got high i didn't get high at the club
i didn't hit on any of the waitress i
got hired my cousins
friday whatever saturday i got high in
the hotel you could the condo was so bad
the condo didn't even have a [ __ ]
a shower curtain i mean i had to stay
with my cousin
the point of the story is i came home
and three months later some headliner
comes up to me goes hey man what'd you
do in west palm beach that owner will
hate you
he says you were doing [ __ ] blow
okay the owner was doing blow on
saturday and sunday [ __ ] night in the
green room with the other comic that was
at the because they had davey and they
had whatever it doesn't really matter
who the [ __ ] it was but it's amazing how
people will say [ __ ] it depends how we
take it i was very insulted and i saw
him after that i never talked to him
again ever since then things have
changed and now when i see him he's my
best friend and he wants to talk and
you're doing great
but it's [ __ ] crazy yeah i was at the
store one night in the very beginning
97 and i went to the door guy and i
asked him for blow and i gave him 100
bucks and he gave me six twenties for a
hundred
so i had six twenties i think i had an
audition the next morning i was gonna do
two of them
i had four of them that i would have
given away you know i'm saying yeah
i do a couple bumps a comic comes in
there well known come he comes in i just
met him and he goes hey man
i'm [ __ ] exhausted i go you want a
blast he goes yeah
i give him two blasts and i go hey take
one of the packages do you know a month
later he went to a pitch meeting and my
name came up and the guy called me a
coke fiend
no
after i gave him
a famous guy yeah pretty much you're not
going to name him no
are you friends with his family he
apologized since then i hit him up he
did yeah
when it comes to industry dude oh my god
somebody [ __ ] you with industry oh he
had tears in his eyes he did that yo he
had
i was gonna kill him for you just
because i was really mad when i was
telling them i went and banged going out
sat there and sweated out in that hot
[ __ ] trail until i figured out there
was air conditioning i sat in there like
a [ __ ] victim in one of those uh like
adam sandler in the box i didn't know it
was air conditioning this was my first
anything you just like and the trailer
was the size of this
it was the size of this
this is how big this is how much money
they spent back then this is
15 years ago i didn't know nothing only
that day i'm not gonna lie to people i
don't i didn't know nothing there was no
acting class
i knew the comedy store 11 45
if i got there before paul mooney if he
was running late i get 11 45 before who
was the chick that moved to new york
that looked like a man
but my bacon no no
she would be
hysterical you don't know nothing lee
and all of a sudden they call for you in
the trailer and they fight you yeah
they're ready for you you walk down and
they go you gotta stand on your line
stand on your mark what [ __ ] what mark
are you talking about yeah i don't know
and they're putting bean bags on my feet
and i'm like what the [ __ ] this is like
you're getting shot on the jib yeah what
the [ __ ] is it what are you talking
about
okay action i said my line that line i
must have said 80 times when i walked
off that said i go i'll never work again
that was my movie career down the tube
we're doing this podcast [ __ ] revealing
ourselves
saying things that we shouldn't be
saying but still like this is the most
freeing thing
i've ever done in my career which is
this podcast [ __ ] i love it i love it
too dude because we get to be together
as a family i get to see your little
[ __ ] cuban titties sticking out that
white shirt you like that not really no
what are you gonna do i never do nothing
i'm not gonna do nothing but your
titties are sticking i love two blocks
around the corner
look at his little [ __ ] green little
little titties there oh he's [ __ ] up
he's got the [ __ ] you got a little good
titties huh he's got a the what's the
guy that killed the tupac
big yeah you got biggie's little white
teddy oh no what's up
my first threesome at 35
36 and it was one of the worst things of
my life yeah like two girls and one guy
two girls you've never done a threesome
with two guys one girl no no i have a
couple times looking at another guy nate
what is that comics i did it with mike
burton
you know mike burton is no mike burns is
a stand-up yeah yeah he's still around
yeah yeah yeah yeah mike burton and a
feature the girl i can't say her name
because she's still around and we do the
threesome and um
he was so selfish
because you know i mean he would pull
her up to his side of the bed i don't
want to touch him so you know what i
ended up doing going to the side a bit
and just masturbating watching them and
we also can i just say something we all
laughed
so much it was like the funnest sex i've
ever really ever had you know and i did
it with aaron cater
and brian etheridge once in vegas too
that three that was a five seven i was
gonna say where's the five something you
don't know
where did you meet the two girls dude um
this is so gross
so um you know what you know steve
saripa yeah so schrippa riviera yeah so
he calls me and goes
you know because dice used to call me
ching
right
so so steve stripper used to call me
ching
is chi-ching that's what they used to
say not racial but i know it was racial
so you're hing i go hey we're doing this
midnight dirty show i want you to
headline i'd never headline before so
brian etheridge and aaron cater were
open micros at the time
we'll drive you i mean we'd love to see
that right so they drove me out there so
we're on las vegas boulevard these two
sisters drive by right and brian atheros
is driving and the two sisters roll down
the window they go you're cute
not to brian because he's the ugliest
white dude i've ever seen or me if they
were saying it to cater kate is a
[ __ ] cute boy good looking yeah good
looking kid right cater runs out of the
car jumps in this [ __ ] truck they
drive out into the sunset right and me
and brian are [ __ ] mad all right so
then we get to the riviera i go brian
you go do your own thing i have to
concentrate right on my set list or
whatever so then midnight i'm literally
on stage and i see brian and aaron bring
in these two sisters one was like a 300
pound white lit girl and the other one
was 80 pounds but they were sisters and
they were missing teeth
but you know at the time you know i need
you know so anyway after the show aaron
goes hey
don't do us
so let's go to the room so we're in the
room and
so you know you're no condom either you
know i mean i know so we were doing it
you know doing it and doing it and then
all of a sudden like three hours later
i'm with the fat one and aaron's with
this skinny one i don't know what brian
is
i don't know where brian is
so i look around the room i don't know
what brian is maybe he's in the bathroom
you know he's not in the bathroom
so i keep doing i'm doing but doggy
style with this fat one
and i feel something tickling my
butthole
it was like a feather you know what i
mean i turn around
not no one's there
so it was like paranormal
you know what i mean i thought that was
like a paranormal tickling yeah yeah
yeah
but then like i keep going and i find
and then i definitely feel something you
know like object like something you know
i mean and i look down
brian had crawled underneath my body
and he was eating her [ __ ] while i'm
having sex with her now let me tell you
something
let me tell you something you have to
imagine what is on his face now at this
point you know my little goop juice
he's got [ __ ] juice fat juice you know
what i mean mixed together you know i
mean who knows what kind of you know
why not just go for the [ __ ] what is
he i don't know but he goes she likes it
she likes it i don't like it because
it's like
his chin is rubbing against my taint i
don't like it
it's weird
right i can't get hard so it's just it
gets worse
so i decided to power fogger
right so i go
you know how you're doing paro
i'm not gonna get in trouble for the
same time
[ __ ] nobody in 10
years that you know what i mean and you
know i slipped out right so i tried to
stick it back in and but brian had moved
up right and it rubbed against his eye
right so then we all disband you know i
mean because like he screamed you know
what i mean
and like what we gotta fight
like why are you down there you know man
you purposely i didn't purposely
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]